what is the purpose of Discovery call in
your point of view I think it's to
really understand those pain points and
dig deeper into those because sometimes
there's pain points that they don't even
realize that they had that you're
uncovering making them kind of
understand that pain and how we could be
a solution to the problem that they have
I think just really understand how this
higher that we're going to help them
with is going to help them meet those
goals just sometimes they think they
need one thing but actually we've worked
with other companies where something
else has been more successful so
sometimes for example a prospect will
come to a saying we need an STL with two
years experience it's an entry-level job
but we need to use experience so you
don't need that experience you need
someone with the right potential and is
gonna
grow with the business